i'll be money first of all big
congratulations from everybody here at
the saint louis chess club this might be
one of your biggest victory up to date
at least rating performance wise you won
25 rating points or something along
those lines you scored six and a half
points out of seven in the last seven
rounds how do you feel you must be
feeling euphoric at this point yes this
is a dream come true i mean just to play
in this event is
i was very happy just to get in to get
an invitation to this event now to
completely win this by in such a
dominating fashion six and a half out of
seven it feels amazing when you started
off with that loss in your second round
were you still thinking about winning
the event at all
i mean at like before the event i was
thinking about winning the event but
then i was just thinking game per game
like okay this game didn't go well but
like you can't after at the start of
round one if you lose the game you can't
just say that oh i want to win the event
like you have to you have to
yeah like you can
yeah so i was thinking on game after
game like what i can what i can improve
on the second game and then i kept on
playing and
yeah everything worked out what would
you say was that a crucial moment when
you first started dreaming about winning
the event in which round did that key
i mean it didn't like i wasn't like
throughout the event i of course i
wanted to win the event
but the thing was i wasn't exact i
wasn't thinking about that i was
thinking about game per game as such but
yeah in the last two three rounds
everything it looked much more realistic
than at the start of the tournament we
didn't get a chance to speak with you
yesterday after he defeated repco how
did that feel
catching up with the leader
the
dominant leader up to that point
yeah it felt amazing as such because the
reason was that ravka he had this
amazing four out of four in the start
and he was he was winning every game
nevertheless whether even when he was
losing he or winning or whatever it was
he was winning every single game and to
beat him with the black pieces
was it was just it was amazing and it
gave me even more realistic chances
because if i drew that game today i
probably wouldn't be i wouldn't have won
the tournament because that maximum i
would get a tie break you definitely
were on a mission today against one of
your closest rivals that is christopher
you let's take a look at that game oh
yeah uh let me bring it up real quick
here it felt
i felt that he chose an
opening that
i really don't know the
the realistic evaluation of this g5 line
yeah my guess is whitish white should be
better here with precise play but of
course it's very sharp yeah this knight
b1 has been really the bane of this of
this line for those that are following
this knight b1 is really cute it
actually took forever to find it
a lot of
chess focus was on dtake c5 and even the
move h3 for some time but knight b1 once
people figured out that you can just
give up this pawn on d4 and get a very
nice initiative
uh i think the switch here yeah i think
b6 is a bit is inaccurate as such
because the reason is after if you play
g5 you have to break my center down like
in general in this kind of french
structures you either have to play f6
and try to break my structure down on
the on the king side with f6 and
like take off this e5 pawn or you'd like
here he's playing g5 that means he wants
to play g4 and take d4 right but if you
play g5 and you don't get to play g4 and
take d4 why should black should be
like worse
yeah especially in this kind of
situation yeah this a3 idea was nice but
the idea is like uh there are some other
french advanced structures like i think
it was there are a few lines that go
like e4 e6 d4 d5
uh what was it e5 c5 c3 knight c6 and i
have three queen b6 and a3 is a move
here right right with the idea of b4 so
i try to do the same thing here to to
relieve the tension in the center
right and it seems that
here came the what we think is the the
big strategical mistake from black
of opening the f file uh actually the
engine liked black after the move g4
but of course it's still very
complicated it lights black
just a little bit like point point three
point four i forgot but g4 was very
important
f4
this also looks pretty fine for white
but yeah the snare on e1 is
a bit restricted i guess the difference
is that he doesn't have that big
weakness on h5 among other things among
other things but certainly
uh after gta x4 bishop to xf4 you must
be feeling good about this position at
least the potential uh plans here and
you played just really really well uh i
think this was a very mis-timed
f6 a little hopeful
but but at the same time if you don't go
for f6 i mean i'll play queen e3 and i
have three and if you you can't keep
playing with the pawn on f7 eventually
i'll double up play bishop g5 and
it'll be too much for black to handle so
like maybe this is the best practical
chance as such but it's not a good
position for black at all absolutely but
here it already seemed that
the position was falling apart and
indeed after king takes uh this is just
over right yeah like e4 i have queen g4
or anything yeah there are a few like
very nice tactics here after rook test
f1 rook takes f1 e64
i think the idea was my idea was like
okay maybe queen g4 was a bit stronger
but okay i don't really care as such ctx
d4 knight takes d4 my idea was queen g4
check and this was a shocking moment for
us and i would assume for you as well
knight 64 with you having only eight
minutes on the clock felt like the
required decision for him to at least
make you calculate and find the winning
uh path yes but i have this very nice
move here knight d e4
the idea is detect c4 rook d1 now bishop
d5 is the only move not to lose your
queen and now knight takes c4 and i play
rook test d5 and f6 is just over
yeah i mean that works
it's one of the many ways that this
works but this is good enough it looked
clean enough clean enough for sure
uh yeah
i guess uh there are more than one
solution after the next d4 we still felt
he had to go for it and this is this is
a this at least after queen f4 you're
not resigning immediately
and the game yeah you probably win most
of it almost all the time with blight
here in this position but in the other
variation he was just completely
hopeless yeah an idea of three then i
have seven was it was a threat and yeah
it's we have seven h5 everything is
winning right well abi remind you
congratulations on this one tell us a
little bit about your coming plans as a
chess player what's on the horizon
yeah so my my next tournament i'm
probably going to play another
tournament another like five six days at
charlotte chess center
and after that uh
there are a few other tournaments lined
up like maybe like some plans to europe
like these very
these very strong open tournaments like
reykjavik
and so on
yeah reykjavik coming up in april
actually a a lovely tournament i'm very
sad i'm not going this year but i've had
i've had great experiences there
definitely switching wishing you the
best of luck thank you
uh all right kristin any questions
no just i'm stunned by a great
performance and i want to congratulate
abi manu once again congratulations and
good luck in the rest of your events
this year we're looking forward to a
surging 26 2700 who knows thank you
that's my plan yeah that's what we
expect the pressure is on you and
remember that he will be back here
abimanu mishra for the us juniors in
july so certainly look for his return to
the club very soon and hopefully we get
to see him play the u.s championships
very very soon in the next uh if not
this year maybe the next year
wow what an impressive young man
alejandro yeah very 13 years of age very
eloquent very outspoken and i like the
enthusiasm he has for chess and the more
i see him analyze the more i'm convinced
that he just calculates to the end he
just he's the real deal he's just a real
deal he calculates everything
and i'm very impressed by his and by his
performance so far all right there are
no huge updates in the key matchups
mainly because they're finished but in
the in the one and the other one with
jeffrey well